- - Bruno Pelletier, j'ai adoré
vovotre nouvelle biographie pare
quque vous êtes une personne
trtrès discrète.
- - Oui.
- - Mais là, vous vous confiez
cocomme jamais auparavant.
EtEt dans le livre, vous parlez
dede vos débuts, de cette périoe
"g"glam rock", sexe, drogue,
rorock-and-roll.
VoVous parlez d'acide, de cocaï.
BRBRUNO PELLETIER, chanteur
- - Ouié Oui, mais attendez.
(r(rires)
J'J'étais pas... on va dire, ona
didire comme c'est, j'étais pas
susur la poudre à tous les soir,
j'j'étais pas capable de chanter
dede toute façon en faisant de a
drdrogue. J'ai fait cette vie-là
dadans les années 80 d'un gars
dadans la vingtaine qui essaie
dedes choses, mais rapidement,
jeje me suis rendu compte et ça,
c'c'est à cause du sport et des
ararts martiaux, que la disciple
quque j'ai dans ces disciplines-
llà, il fallait que je l'appliqe
àà mon métier rapidement
sisi je voulais vraiment faire a
cocomme métier.
D Donc j'ai complètement arrêté
totout ça à un moment donné. Pus
ilil y a eu comme une épiphanie,
çaça s'est passé sur un soir
àà Sept-Îles.
EtEt il est 4 h du matin,
jeje me vois dans le miroir aprs
unune nuit de bamboche avec toue
lala gang. Et puis j'ai fait
cocomme : OK, non, ça marche pa,
llà, on peut pas aller là,
j'j'y arriverai jamais.
♪♪ Sur ton passage ♪
- ApAprès les bars, votre carrie
a a changé du tout au tout
auau début des années 90 après
unune rencontre avec Luc Plamonn
paparce qu'il vous a embauché
popour "La légende de Jimmy",
"S"Starmania".
- - Oui.
- - Quels souvenirs gardez-vous
dede dette période-là?
- - Pour le p'tit cul de
ChCharlesbourg, qui rêvait juste
dede jouer du drum sur la scène
dede la polyvalente, se ramasser
àà Paris tout d'un coup,
c'c'était... Hein!
EtEt à Paris en famille avec
IsIsabelle, la mère de mon fils,
momon fils, qui était encore
auaux couches, le chien...
CÇa a été toute une "ride" et
onon est parti à Paris en 93, ps
jeje vais m'en souvenir toute ma
vivie. C'est dans les plus bells
anannées de ma vie, je pense,
paparce qu'il y avait encore
unune...
- - Innocence?
- - Innocence, une naïveté,
unune innocence. Tu plonges dans
dadans l'inconnu, puis tu y vas
cocomme tous les projets
quque je fais : "all in"!
♪♪ L'homme a voulu monter
vevers les étoiles ♪
♪♪ Écrire son histoire ♪
- - Vous avez été le premier
GrGringoire dans "Notre-Dame
dede Paris", c'était le succès
inincroyable, planétaire.
CoComment avez-vous réussi à
nene pas vous perdre là-dedans?
PaParce que là, c'est l'argent,
c'c'est travailler tout le temp.
C'C'est... c'est fou, là!
- - Un divorce... Pas me perdre?
JeJe pense que je me suis perdu
unun peu. T'as d'un côté tout
cece que t'as rêvé d'avoir.
TuTu fais des tournées,
dedes autobus de tournée, des fs
papartout, tu gagnes des trophé,
t't'as ça d'un côté; et de l'aue
t't'as ta vraie vie, ton père qi
esest malade, un enfant à éleve,
dedes problèmes familiaux,
unun éventuel divorce...
TuTu vis tout ça en parallèle.
EtEt est-ce que j'ai perdu pied?
PePeut-être pendant un bout de
tetemps. Je pense que j'ai assez
dede valeurs profondes et ancrés
popour savoir que j'ai jamais
cocomplètement dérapé.
J'J'ai tout le temps...
j'j'ai toujours gardé ma tête
mamais à un moment donné,
sese sentir complètement dépass,
çaça oui.
- - Parce qu'il y en eu
unun burn-out en 2001.
- - Il y en a eu un en 2001,
pupuis il y a eu un autre,
jeje dirais non diagnostiqué,
mamais tous les signes physiques
ététaient là après "Dracula",
plplus tard, où là, je suis allé
auau bout de quelque chose dans
mama vie que je referai jamais
etet j'ai compris quelque chose
paparce que ça m'a pris du temps
àà revenir. Donc il y a eu deux
momoments dans ma vie où il y au
dedes espèces de burn-out à caue
quque tu vis des choses énormes.
PuPuis il y a pas de manuel 101
popour gérer ça. Et t'arrives en
faface des gens, les journalist,
leles caméras, mais tu montres s
çaça.
♪♪ Dans ma tête
jeje suis le plus grand ♪
- - À la fin de votre livre,
vovous abordez un sujet tabou
auau Québec : l'argent.
- - Ah! Oui, oui.
- - Vous dites que vous avez peu
50500 000 $ au début des années
202000.
- - À peu près, en tout, oui.
- - Ça fait mal, ça, pour une
cacarrière, parce qu'un artiste
a a besoin d'avoir la tête libre
enen fait de problèmes financie.
- - Oui.
- - Comment ça s'est passé
popour vous?
- - En fait, ce qui s'est passé,
c'c'est que j'ai... j'avais
unun rapport à l'argent
cocomme bien des artistes :
j'j'en avais jamais!
(r(rires)
J'J'en avais pas jusqu'à la fin
dedes années 90, début 2000
ouoù là, mes albums personnels
cocommençaient à me rapporter
etet "Notre-Dame de Paris" est
ararrivée dans ma vie et là,
totout a changé et je sais pas
ququoi faire avec ça.
DoDonc j'ai fait confiance
àà des gens et j'ai j'ai perdu
dede l'argent. J'ai perdu
bebeaucoup... En fait, j'ai peru
cocomme une retraite, l'équivalt
pepeut-être d'une retraite.
EtEt donc, c'est des gros montas
d'd'argent qui sont partis
àà cette époque-là.
- - Ça fait mal, ça, parce que
vovous l'avez pas dépensé en
FeFerrari ou en Lamborghini.
- - Ou en studio ou un condo das
lele Sud, comme bien des gens.
- - Oui, oui, oui!
- - Non, je travaillais tellemet
quque j'ai eu l'idée de dire :
JeJe vais mettre ça de côté en
atattendant, puis je verrai plus
tatard ce que je fais avec ça.
♪♪ J'ai l'air, j'ai peur
j'j'ai froid, j'me meurs ♪
- - Vous parlez aussi de
lala soixantaine, plus difficile
àà vivre que la cinquantaine por
vovous, mais vous voyez l'avenir
avavec optimisme.
- - Bien, un optimisme pondéré
dadans le sens que je suis
tetellement conscient que
lele métier d'artiste, c'est
dedes montagnes russes, alors en
cece moment, je suis dans un beu
"h"high", je dirais; quand je vs
sesentir que je ne suis plus
cacapable de le donner, je vais
papas juste m'accrocher
àà la nostalgie, là, je vais...
QuQuand je vais sur scène, c'est
totoujours, comme paraphraser
leles sportifs, c'est toujours
popour mon 150 %. Donc quand
jeje sentirai que je ne suis pls
cacapable de le faire, je vais
meme retirer, ça, c'est sûr.
- - Je vous rassure, c'est loin
d'd'être terminé, si on se fie
auaux ovations après la reprise
dede "Notre-Dame de Paris". Meri
bebeaucoup , Bruno Pelletier.
- - Merci beaucoup à vous.
♪♪ Est prévue pour l'an 2000 ♪
(a(applaudissement